What's kind of cool about mean-shift,
a bunch of things,
is under some reasonable
assumptions like the,
the shape of the thing that you put
down which is a kernel kind of thing,
you can prove that, in most
circumstances, this thing will converge.
So, it'll actually find those modes.
And that's really cool.
So what does this have to do
with tracking, you might ask.
>> What does this have
to do with tracking?
>> So basically,
mean-shift tracking is, instead of just
tracking the mean of a distribution,
we're going to try to track,
essentially, a, something about
a distribution of a region.
I'll, I'll make that clear.
But our methodology is
pretty similar to before.
We have some position that
we start with, right?
And here, by the way, our initial
model is not just a location.
But it's this region and
the size of that region.
And what we have to do is we search.
We're going to search in
a neighborhood in the next frame for
that same description.
Okay?
And when we do the search,
we're going to move around at x y.
We also might do things like
change the scale, all right?
And what we want to do is, we want to
find the lo, the new location,
maybe scale,
maybe some other ch, change.
Maybe an orientation thing.
That maximizes some similarity function.
All right?
And then we just, iterate.
We connect the dots.
And we repeat the process and we get
this beautiful animation that says,
okay, the new maximum becomes
the start for the next frame.